He's like,
yeah,
I'm on the fucking,
what the fuck you doing?
He goes,
you think this is a bad neighborhood?
And he goes,
I just put on a Russian accent.
Everyone's scared of me.
It's like Russians are the scariest white people.
They're definitely not regular white people and the women are the worst.
Arlene Russian women,
they will fucking cut you and laugh at your bleeding.
Whoa.
They're merciless.
My mom,
my grandma,
they would do not fuck around deaf from the old country.
What about Russia woman that you encountered today?
Their worst cause they're liberated.
So they're there.
They're ruthless.
They're very hot.
Crazy in the head.
Crazy in the bed.
Yeah,
but I,
I can't do it.
What?
That band that the documentary was the could get arrested.
Pussy riot.
Yeah.
Those bitches are low.
I've got to push it.
Free Pussy riot tee shirt.
I don't even know what they did wrong,
but just I'm wearing that shirt.
Yeah.
That's the,
it's ballsy to criticize Putin.
Oh yeah.
Mean that is,
I don't care if you're a band or you're a journalist,
like whenever you're doing that guy has killed a lot of people and laughs about
it.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know the Superbowl ring story?
No,
you don't know that.
I want to hear this.
Oh fine.
Google it.
So I don't fuck up the stats because a Sturgill Simpson actually told me this.
The um,
there was a super bowl winner who visited Putin and as he's talking to Putin,
Putin asks him to see the ring.
He's got the soup bowl rang and Putin holds onto it,
puts it on his finger and walks away and then the guy starts going,
hey,
what the fuck?
And Putin's body guards would put their hand on the guy like,
no,
it's over.
Oh yeah,
your fucking ring.
Yes.
My friend Sandy Weill,
we have just given all the rings.
I showed sandy my ring and he said,
why don't you show it to the president?
I showed it to him and they put it on and he sort of enjoyed it.
So we kept it on.
He gets his version of it there.
There's a version of it in an actual article that's more detailed where he talks
about how they,
you know,
he asked for it back and they were like,
no,
here's what happened.
The other thing is how he trailed Angela Merkel.
You know this story now,
Angela Merkel is head of German chancellor Germany.
She's terrified of dogs.
So he brings out his giant black lab,
which are the sweetest braid.
And this photo is look up Merkel Putin dog.
And she's sitting there terrified to look at it and the dog sniffing her.
It's like a lab and he's just sitting there fucking laughing like an asshole.
And he's like,
oh,
I didn't know she was scared of dogs.
I'm like,
how many world leaders are you're bringing your dog out to meet other than her
and the body language and her.
Yeah,
her,
she's freaking the fuck out.
Oh,
look at her and look at it shows like a little scared of dogs either,
by the way,
at a lab.
Come on.
Yeah.
Fucking weird.
She's like,
Eh,
not fart.
And I learned that was so funny.
Yeah,
he's an asshole.
He's,
um,
it's,
it's very strange what he's been able to do.
Oh yeah.
Did you see the assassination attempt where the guy drove into his car,
full clip,
changed lanes on the highway and went into the oncoming lane into the fast lane
on the other side.
Full clips slammed into his car and killed his driver,
but he wasn't in the car.
Oh my God.
No,
it's why holy,
Holy Shit,
it's wild.
It was an assassination attempt and they just didn't know that he wasn't in the
car,
but the fact they were able to cut through the lanes,
get into the center where you know they're there,
they have access to the oncoming lanes and pick his car right out of all the
car.
I mean,
it had to be coordinated with someone.
Right.
Cause there's gotta be a motorcade,
right?
Because,
well they're,
oh yeah.
Wow.
Oh that's it already.
Oh,
just keeps running it by.
but just do it from the beginning.
The beginning wasn't gold.
There's a better version of it then there's a better version of it out there and
the better version of it.
You see the guy changed lanes.
Boom.
Yeah.
And Slam in and had to know that that's where his car was killed.
Him killed the driver.
But Putin was not in the car but it was Putin's car.
It's magic.
Well he just knew probably something was up.
I mean he must have a bunch of people feeding them information all the time.
And how many SAS nation attempts have there been on that guy?
Well,
I mean what about the assassination of sun on the presidents that we don't hear
about?
Both Obama and Trump.
There've been plenty.
Really?
Yes.
Like what ones do you look at?
I,
I mean they just Trump.
Yes.
Really?
A red horse.
Yes.
I haven't heard anything of course.
Cause they don't want to talk about it cause then he hit the victim and it,
and also you don't want to get these people's attention.
In all fairness.
I think that's a good move to be like,
all right,
let's not talk about this.
Like you don't want to talk about when terrorist attacks are foiled because then
they'll know,
okay this doesn't work.
We're going to try it a different way.
So that's smarter,
that press,
I think,
you know,
but I mean,
he's been able to run Russia for a long time.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
he had his number,
it was like Teddy Roosevelt and Taft.
He had his number two,
there was term limits.
He goes,
you're going to be present.
And I was like,
okay,
I'm done and I'm going to be back in.
And the guy's like,
okay,
here you go,
Mr Putin.
But that's what's crazy is he got back in and everybody's like,
okay.
And His approval rating.
So like 70% or something crazy.
There are some huge number.
The Russians Lovell,
do they love him or do they say they love him cause they're scared?
No,
Russians love aggression.
We love someone who is nasty and an asshole.